also you have to
well i i recommend that
you challenge me to five minute games if
you're slightly lower rated so that we
have more
or rather i have more time to try and
instruct and discuss the game
and apart from that
let's play three minutes to make it um
more exciting sporting contest okay so
we have
yusuf 4646 from
uh from turkey um once again i think
a lot of turkish turkish players here
are challenging
just um obviously nice to see the
the interest there um
and we have a yeah pretty sharp knight
or
bishop d3 i guess is a bit unusual
doesn't look like a bad move though
okay let me go e6
um the only question is really whether
the moves um
the moves bishop d3 and um
i'll go b5 as a matter of fact e5 a4
though
that should be fine um whether
bishop d3 and bishop g5 fit because
one of the most bishop d3 really really
hints at
um an aggressive setup with later
forward bishop d3 is more
um usually in connection with castles
and
um and all that so now
i yeah with s3 as well i've played
somewhat similar setups with with white
so i wouldn't say it's it's bad at
all but it's obviously not the most
challenging
indents that i can now i can now develop
quite
quite freely especially with
long uh with short slow which is
something i
generally wouldn't really recommend here
um because
yeah um there isn't too much pressure on
my
my position and with short castle that
also means that
there won't be any attacking option
which means that black is as is fine
seeing as structurally black is doing
fine white usually needs to to attack in
order to
justify his play
uh so with all that talk
yeah let's go 95 it seems very
reasonable
putting the knights on a good central
square i think f4 is never really a good
idea and
connection with king side counseling so
he goes
he goes bishop f1 instead which seems
very very sensible
uh queen b6 now is played just in order
to provoke
hp3 then i'll go queen c7 and
i'll claim that it's a slight
achievement for
for me um that
yeah the bishop is a little less active
on
on on e3 than it would have been on um
on on g5 don't know if that's
anything real though knight b3
don't really know what that
all about usually in the sicilian if you
can play
d5 with the impunity you should do it so
i'll try and see if it works out well
here
um there are some tricks though
of for instance my intention was
here after general after a lot of trades
in the center let's say knight d5
bishop d5 bishop f4
the idea was to go quintix c2 because
the knight on b3 will be hanging
but i did miss though is queen takes c2
queen
rook takes c2 and then knight to d4
and um this
as far as i can see leads me to lose a
piece
so i have to find something else but
fortunately bishop d6
seems quite quite sufficient
and it also introduces a pretty big
threat
which is to go um knight xf3 which he
incidentally missed knight x f3 and long
bishop takes f4
and this will not only knock me upon but
it will also
let me a very very strong pair of
bishops
and this should should mean that
his position is um is kind of collapsing
i don't see any reason not to take
another pawn
and uh obviously now two pawns up with
uh with all the positional trumps
should be should be winning
yeah b4 this should take it easy
double the rooks it's never hurt anyone
and it's really hard to
to find good advice there for for white
i can't take another pawn wish pass
three
i guess i'll do it i don't love it but
if i start teaching people not to take
completely free pawns
that i'm doing something wrong and this
after all
is supposed to be educational
okay uh rook t4
yeah g5 looks too natural not to be
played
fortifying that uh bishop on a nice
outpost where he cannot be attacked by
any white
on rook d1 nissan is another blunder
because the bishop e3 i think i will
just go rook c2 as a matter of fact
could have taken the rook then rook c1
followed by rook a1
meaning i'll be at full rook up but i
think
this is a faster way to the gold
um yeah rook d3 but that doesn't prevent
the main threat which
which is rook h2 and knight okay he
resigned in time
okay not a bad game at all by my
opponent
uh it was just playing a little too
too passively they're allowing me to
to build up the the pressure
okay